hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch from
the channel Doug Doug
this guy has over four hundred thirty
thousand subscribers he is killing it
right now this is a top reward tier
video request from a man named Colin
Anderson has his own YouTube channel you
guys should go check it out link in the
description box this video that we're
gonna watch it a over watch vs
Terminator 2 but explained with food
let's get into this I think overwatch
vs. tf2 is like making dessert playing
overwatch is like you're baking a
gourmet cake there's six of you you're
in a kitchen together and every chef has
one specific cake ingredient that
they're adding the tank puts in the
flour then the DPS is and the sugar in
the eggs in the oint then the supports
and the baking soda and the chocolate
that brings it all together all six
chefs here must work in concept great to
nail this recipe and if they do this
cake will be one of the best you've ever
eat
that's overwatch Team Fortress 2 is like
eating a candy bar candy bars Buffy's
great on their own like you don't need
any other foods to make a Snickers taste
good ok let's say you're eating a
Snickers and then you see two other guys
eating tf2 candy bars so you say to them
hey let's team up let's merge our candy
bars into one super dish and they're
like yeah so you throw in your stingers
and that guy throws in dem events he
throws in a medic cookie and that guy
adds Hershey's weapons guy and then well
then it just tastes like a big chocolaty
mess but here's the thing
Snickers by itself tastes like a big
chocolaty mess so does Hershey syrup
combining candy bars together doesn't
make them taste any better it's still
just a pile of delicious chocolate
either way no ads - so why are they
being so different well overwatch
characters are fundamentally designed to
stay next to each other don't lose the
chocolate protect me from a tank's
shield or to be healed by a support you
have to stand next to the tank or the
support it's just like the ingredients
of a cake they are designed and to taste
better when you mix them together so if
your junk rat you're going to be more
powerful by sticking with your team and
utilizing their buffs this is true
Ultimates - they are designed to be far
more powerful
you coordinate them with your teammates
so alts primarily serve to reward
teamwork this is what makes overwatch so
satisfying because if your team works
well together you're rewarded by
becoming substantially more powerful and
it's a rush so teamwork is what makes
overwatch fun but these super powerful
team synergies also mean you have very
limited freedom to play this game your
own way and really can't be effective
with a solo play style and overwatch
because by design you are far less
powerful without your teammates buffs
this gets worse when the meta game has a
clearly defined optimal composition like
dive in this case the synergies between
specific characters are so strong that
you are any substantial disadvantage if
you play anything like the Spice Girls
Red Mill the Saturday I love making red
velvet [ __ ] no chocolate cake is the
only dessert in the meta I'm reporting
you
the second big problem is that because
teamwork is so crucial to winning if you
have just one or two bad teammates that
can ruin the entire game like if you
were making a cake and your tank
carefully adds the flower and then you
perfectly add in sugar and then this
dudes just eating Khan's Oreos now the
entire cake you were making is gonna
taste awful because that guy is refusing
never playing this game with John that's
true and since you get I'm a good cookie
the game it's totally hit or miss of
actually having a team that coordinates
well it has fun it's like you're at a
restaurant where half the meals cause
horrible vomiting but the other half
it's like the best steak you've ever had
but people keep eating overwatch because
god damn dude the rush when your team
pulls it all off is just incomparable
like every chef on the team just nailed
their job and we made a cake so good it
made Jeff Caplan cry in tf2 most
characters aren't designed to benefit
their teammates in any way soldier demo
and scowl etc don't have any core ludes
that benefit their teammates and so you
can run off on your own without being
any fun just looks cool this means
you're interactiveness as a player is
only dictated by you not by your
teammates behaviour tf2 characters are
candy bars they taste great on their own
they don't need anyone else's flavors
engineer and medic are the two obvious
exceptions here they are very much
designed to benefit teammates and help
you win but winning the game just isn't
really a priority in tf2 people don't
really care about the objective itself
it just serves as the dedicated spot
where everybody's going to blow each
other up the
almost discourages you from trying too
hard to win by frequently scrambling
with teams or even if you and two other
guys are like hey you want to team up
and defend the objective spies and
Pyro's and snipe iers roaming around
having whatever little adventures pop up
and 90% of the time you'll never
properly coordinated anyone don't get me
wrong
teamwork is still really fun in tf2 but
unlike overwatch it's not the entirety
of the game and instead you have this
incredible freedom to play in whatever
style you want plus tf2 maps are usually
12 B 12 or more whereas overwatch is
only 66 this means that every individual
overwatch player has a larger impact on
their team's product so there's more
pressure for you to follow the recipe
and not be a dick there are exceptions
to all of this teamwork at tf2 is
definitely affected when it's done well
in the competitive modes like 6s or
Highlander are a great example of this
and there's definitely some overwatch
players who do find success by playing
separately from their teams but the
underlying design of these games funnels
players into a teamwork mentality or a
solo mentality so that 90% of the time
in overwatch you need to stick to the
recipe and 90% of the time in tf2 you're
in a Snickers dance party yeah outside
of teamwork I think the games are mostly
differ in how you can customize your
experience for example customizing each
character in tf2 they treat each
character like a fruit and let's say you
taste each one and then you go [ __ ]
because we have different ways to eat
apples
we got apple pie and apple sauce and
baked apples and apple fritters and tons
more this is how tf2 classes work
there's only nine classes but each one
has three changeable weapon slots with
hundreds of possible combinations so if
I love the taste of demo banana I can
mix it up and swap in Scottish
resistance and now cover choke points
it's similar but it's customized for now
I swap in storage boots and I'm playing
demo Mennonite and you're like this is
awesome they took a food I loved demo
mañana and they're giving me different
ways to cook that cool flavor whereas
overwatch is like you guys we have 29
different fruits and veggies to choose
from I'm like oh my god there are some
really genuinely unique options here
like a McCree comer or a Reaper simin or
a wreckin bell pepper
hey get out of here that's a fruit but
overwatch hasn't given multiple remelt
application really heavy allowed to eat
them raw so let's say you try them all
out and you go Widow mango is my
favorite fruit I love this flavor and
you're having a great time
eating Widow mango but you might say to
overwatch hey I love the flavor of Widow
mango could you give me some ways to
customize my favorite fruit and
overwatch says here's a briquette and
you're like that's cool man but I really
like widow mango like I would love to
eat that same flavor but in different
styles like a new way to enjoy the food
that I already like and they're like
here's a durian overwatch doesn't let
you customize your favorite characters
instead they just introduce new
characters altogether this is actually a
really great thing if you're a player
who wants a large variety in fundamental
play styles but it also means you might
get tired of that hero that you really
really love a lot faster than you might
otherwise even more broadly tf2 lets the
community customize the maps that you
can play when valve babies tf2 it's like
they opened a restaurant and they said
hey we made a bunch of food and here's
our menu of dishes to choose from but if
the kitchens unlocked feel free to make
whatever else you want so everybody was
in the kitchen and went nuts and over
time the community has cooked all sorts
of insane new dishes for the tf2 menu
but one day when you guys I pack 10
scoops of ice cream in the One Bowl I
call it a 10x credit server another guys
like I took soldier flour and pieces of
toast and created jump maps but that's
actually delicious
and another dudes like you guys I took
that sandwich and I made it really
really tall and that's like a real thing
that people play called higher tower
it's just high tower but the tower is
really tall now wow so over the years
people took TM twos map editor and
custom servers and created crazy new
genres like Jon Salman randomizer tons
more the community expand in tf2 s
restaurant menu to have almost infinite
dishes to choose from and this is
drastically increased the game's
longevity and a joint over what happened
their restaurant they said here's our
menu food you can eat these specific
things and over time they've added new
items to the menu like 3v3 or brawls and
these dishes all taste great but the
point is that overwatch and only
overwatch can
the entire menu and as a result it's a
pretty limited menu like if you go in
there and you try to order a 12 B 12
match they will say sorry but 12 B 12
isn't on our menu why don't you try our
66 and I'm like man and it's great but I
thought it'd be fun to make my own type
of meal and they're like here's a
variant and this isn't so much a flaw of
overwatch it's just a big missed
opportunity they don't give the
community tools to make unique maps and
modes and this unnecessarily limits the
games menu of options and it's
especially frustrating because blizzards
older games did Judas Warcraft 3 is
legendary because of custom maps
Blizzard made these incredible RTS
ingredients and then said hey the
kitchen doors unlocked go make whatever
you want and so some frog started a 5v5
eating contest and literally invented
dota and another dude invented tower
defense and hero arenas and a million
other iconic games Warcraft 3 maybe
ingredients and the community made the
menu and it sucks when you see over
watch's ingredients which are so
creative and cool and you just wonder
what kind of amazing meals we might be
eating if overwatch just let us play
with our food at this point I play more
tf2 but it just depends on how I'm
feeling right like if it's the end of a
long day I want to dig around and play
my favorite character and not worry
about teammates then tf2 is the perfect
experience for me but overwatch can be
[ __ ] awesome the characters and
Ultimates are super creative and if you
have a great team the feeling of working
together and accomplishing a plan is one
of the best feelings in gaming eating
the gourmet cake is always going to
taste better than eating a Snickers it
just really sucks if your cake has Hanzo
in it hey thank you for watching if you
enjoyed subscribing to my channel is
like getting three Snickers sent to your
house only the Snickers tastes like a
shitty video interesting don't sell
yourself short man this was delightful
wow so what I gather from that was that
overwatch is like playing with a team
mm-hm and is like having
some really good dessert yeah and then
the other one tf2 is like he just played
by herself and was like candy I think
yeah yeah but like you should just lay
that out
I feel like this this video could be 20
seconds long but don't get me wrong I
mean I really appreciated the food based
metaphors in the expansion on I mean
this brought me more toward I guess the
team fortress side of things but I don't
know I mean that team element is
something I haven't yet experienced in
any of my gaming aside from like Mario
Party but even then you're not even
really working together all that office
because they're letting people down all
the time John I know I just got to start
saying yes to more thing well you just
got to get better at video games that's
what I say no okay well then I'll change
my priority if you're gonna work with me
on a team and overwatch I'm I need you
to help that game man okay well I got to
pick my role for I mean which game do
you want to play overwatch you're an
overwatch guy okay oh yeah you're the
custom map stuff that always sounds like
really cool and everything but I feel
like I get over that super fast yeah it
seems like why would you get over that
fast when you can trade all these cool
Maps and really mess around there but I
don't know doesn't really like I want
you gonna kill people I want you people
and I get more of a high off of working
with others and working at the team it's
like when I play Halo I prefer to play
with somebody with somebody with khloé'
would somebody as opposed to just
playing by myself I enjoy a communal
thing and I like the idea of how
overwatch in order to succeed in order
to really benefit and grow you have to
have to work together you have to work
together yeah I find it very appealing
burst tf2 is like okay sure you keep
changing up the levels but the gameplay
sounds like it would just be kind of
repetitive and to me it seems like gonna
be a little mundane after a while it
just kind of be the same thing over and
over again just different places to roam
around depending on how well you could
convince somebody to theoretically team
up with yes a thing is like with tf2 it
sounds like you just want to hop on for
a few minutes stick around and have fun
you can but I wonder what I didn't get a
sense for was how likely are you to get
a few people were like yeah let's play
overwatch style in Team Fortress 2 and
see how that goes because it seemed like
the others broader possibilities but at
the end of the day if you're talking
about quality
you know it seems like overwatch is the
place to go yeah it's like an in-and-out
burger it's like limited menu but when
you do the menu really well well I think
a lot factors in with your experience
with Blizzard as well like I'm not one
of those guys who really factors in my
gameplay experience based off of what
other games the company that produces
yeah I don't really factor any of that
in sometimes it's like a parent when I'm
playing oh like oh this team probably
made this one this team probably made
this one but I don't really compare it
in that degree unless it's like a sequel
to a game yeah then I'll compare it but
I like this format that Doug Doug has
assembled here sometimes there's like
these super fast-paced YouTube videos
that are a little bit of a headache to
watch because I just can't keep up
especially for the ones who aren't as
informed like myself or the uninitiated
per se I have a difficult time really
grasping everything that's going on this
was really easy to keep up with I was
surprised with how rapid paced it is and
energetically kinetically edited it was
the entire time I was still able to
follow literally every single step of
the way that he was talking about
despite all these different images being
thrown my way weirdly the food
comparison really does help out a lot
excellent use of visual aids too because
the thing is even when terminology
starts to stretch the boundaries of what
you're familiar with it's like you've
still got that picture of a mango to be
like okay I get it yeah it's like yeah
the use of those little visual touch
stones along with what seems like a
pretty decent metaphor yeah I kind of
agree with you I feel like I walked out
of this with a decent understanding you
couldn't tell us in the comments of this
video in and of itself is accurate but I
feel like I got a pretty good
understanding from this of two games
whose names I've heard for so long him
that I know are huge and now I'm like
okay if I had to jump into one of these
tomorrow I feel like I'd have a sense of
what I was getting into
I would disagree saying that this video
should be 20 seconds long okay no I
don't know I think the it could be
doesn't mean should well how if it could
be out but like I want to have grass the
point of the game that's true other than
if you were to tell me one's like desert
gourmet and then the other one is candy
I would have been like what the hell is
that mean to have like a true and then
I'd be like brain or individual I feel
like is the main core of what you could
have boiled this down to literally the
intricate details of everything he
summarized here I was like I feel like I
really understand both of these games in
inefficient manner and it invested me -
yeah as this was
I was like well you know what I'd
definitely play overwatch over a tf2 TFT
was like the kind of game I put on if I
was like medically marijuana induced and
I just wanted to have a fun time but
overwatch now that's like a party game
and something something you would want
to invest a bit of time in with some
maze and actually maybe even get good at
I guess I've never really lost myself
into customizing either for any of the
games I played there's always those
options but I'm usually like get it over
with
I just want to play the game huh I'll
take whatever model you have presented
for me right now
keep it going you know but I think
that's part of the point is that you
don't even have to do the customs
yourself there are just so many custom
maps and games that are built by just
random people who are just all
contributing them to the community that
the places and styles you can play in
are that much more broad yeah definitely
you know we have to yeah yeah it's like
you don't even have to go in and create
your own if you don't want to yeah like
the graphics for overwatch seem so much
better they do
yeah weirdly seem more seem like there's
some cartoony about tf2 but but a
freaking different way but if you're
gonna go with the overwatch graphics I
can totally see why there's a limitation
on the customization options though
showing us like the World of Warcraft
stuff on like World of Warcraft it's
very lived in experience video game but
you know it's not really known for its
crazy graphics in the gameplay hey you
know what the movie the movie is the
Duncans oh that was great yeah that was
great I'm really underrated
loved that movie so Super Mario Brothers
movie
oh yeah I really enjoyed this Doug Doug
great job on this video man guys please
subscribe if this dudes channel we're
gonna do a right now to fat or something
fat voice just like candy popcorn the
hot dog showed us like he doesn't have a
live a voice that implies that he's
overweight but I'm like he's got real I
know it's as candy yeah yeah it's a
salient metaphor it's I guess yeah right
what you know wouldn't make a difference
I'm eats a lot of candy and has a really
high metabolism uh yeah those guys do
exist
he's one of those dudes naho nope how
can you work out a couple times a week
right now yeah right now there's like a
long period where you weren't really
working out no no you still stayed
really thin yeah I work I also didn't
eat that much fair fair you're trying to
own me on this weight game right here I
lived with you man I saw you you were
the one who always provided the candy
and everything gonna you barely worked
out and so I was like this guy never
gains weight because I have dinner you
have like four tacos at like midnight
and then go to bed
every time and you didn't go three tacos
still you didn't gain weight so I'm like
come on now most people it was my meal
to the death most people eat that late
have that many carbs at night just one
really candy
yeah you still can okay you would have
like little things to eat in between
yeah I'd have a nipple here or there's
some coffee yeah you'd have a muffin
it's like cars is my typical this is all
I'm gonna stay in the video - no it's
all gone anyway subscribe to the real
rejects subscribe to Doug Doug click
that notification bell and Collin
Anderson go check out this dude's
YouTube channel it's called snow
underscore Hawk 92 he loves nature loves
to go on mountains and hiking you thumb
you recently he's gonna be doing a
10,000 foot mountain hike
Thompson peak in Idaho it was beautiful
this guy's crazy that's a great place to
get medically marijuana induced by the
way while you're hiking 10,000 feet I
mean
that level of elevation when you get to
the top I would imagine you'll be so
high elevated that you'll start to float
and you seem it the kind of guy who
would enjoy that as a matter of fact
from looking at your face and knowing
the things you love to do you seem like
the kind of guy my girlfriend would love
so come visit test that theory I don't
know you I don't know you but you could
you lowered your pledge
what are you doing oh nothing remember
inglourious basterds he's the wrong
three or movie to do i did nothing
colin loves that movie and he told me
personally we're done calling you know
you're done don't don't be jealous